all right didn't take long we're now
seeing the real world consequences
of biden's amnesty open borders agenda
for example
the biden administration now is
reportedly moving ahead on plans
to diminish isis enforcement
capabilities and get this
even in places where the border wall is
near complete
it actually has big gaping holes in it
and biden's dhs
wants to leave the giant holes in the
barrier
why would you have a wall with holes in
it senator graham went down to the
arizona mexico border and this is what
he found take a look
the binding administration apparently
has decided
to stop plugging this hole here
what good comes from allowing this hole
to continue to exist
this wall is here for a purpose it keeps
people from coming in our country
legally and you got a hole in the wall
and i'm going to make sure the
department of homeland security
tells me why they're going to stop
finishing this part of the wall it makes
no sense
i don't know senator graham joins us
south carolina senator graham
uh you know you might have a future as a
correspondent for the hannity show
uh in that shot let me tell you i i mean
i'm looking at this
you got i'm trying to understand this
you have holes in the wall
you can't that they were about to finish
you see the equipment is there to finish
the wall
why wouldn't you finish what you started
you already paid for the materials
they're laying there
and not fill the hole that sounds pretty
i don't know where i go
that sounds pretty dumb in new york
if trump did it they're not going to do
it even if it makes sense
so i went to the border open-minded and
i came
back really worried for our country what
you saw
there are 18 holes in this wall near
nogales arizona but on the mexican
u.s border that panels are going to be
put up to allow water to run through
because water runs from mexico in the
united states so they got
ways for the water to get through these
panels well
these were the last panels to go into
the wall
it's like miles of really impressive
fence and walls
the bite administration is not going to
put these panels up
they consider that border wall so you
got
miles of walls with 18 holes in it and
the material to plug the hole
is laying on the ground the border
patrol people
are are just dumbfounded as what to do
all the people remaining in mexico
waiting for their date
uh in the united states for asylum
claims
are being brought back to the united
states and released in the united states
these combination of policies by the
binding administration
are going to lead to caravan after
caravan by june of this year
if the obama administration continues to
dismantle the wall
and change the trump policies about
asylum
we're going to have a million people hit
the border and they already promised
amnesty so that's also part of it and
catch and release
and amazing people don't go to their
court dates
so merrick garland today i mean i find
this pretty interesting
you asked a simple question we have a
smoking gun email james comey did
to james clapper you know what the email
says you even got comey mccabe and yates
to all admit
knowing what they know now they wouldn't
have signed the fisa warrants
comey signed three of them we know on
the day that he signed the second one
the first renewal
before he signed the second renewal of
the third one
uh that he said he couldn't verify the
dossier which was
the bulk of information without which
testimony was given to your committee
they wouldn't have gotten the fisa
warrant and merrick garland didn't have
an opinion about
lying to a fisa court knowing that it
says at the top of a fisa application
verified and it was unverifiable and now
debunked
you know he read the horos report a
review of it a summary of it he said
that was bad and
it should never happen again that if
somebody like kleinsmith altered
documents on his watch
that pay a heavy price i'm confident
that durham's going to be allowed to do
his job if durham is stopped from
continuing the investigation of
crossfire hurricane
that will blow up in their face that'd
be like having a hole in the wall
uh on steroids the policies of the biden
administration on immigration shine
make zero sense they're going to restart
the caravans they've dismantled border
security that was working
they changed policies remaining mexico
that kept people from taking advantage
of
our asylum laws and all this is being
changed because the left is demanding
open borders
i predict this that immigration will be
a bigger issue than 2022
than it was in 2016. so is this going to
be
one where republicans stand together if
you can't answer this fundamental
question
republicans will stand as one this is
that the same republican party that
kind of has some people it might
describe as uh
feckless weak ineffective
lacking courage in the spine some of
them just so
right yeah well if you can't stand up to
this
then you're you're in trouble as a party
what they're doing at the border makes
no sense i've been involved in trying to
fix immigration they're dismantling the
trump border plan that worked
and here's what i would say trump's
going to give a speech sunday
that's going to be very policy-centric
every republican should rally around it
i think it will help us with
independence
and i've never felt better about
president trump's
leading the party than i do right now
let's talk about the president he has a
big speech this weekend at cpac
um i know there might be a couple of
republicans that you know
um that aren't particularly fond of the
president i don't know what maybe they
want to go back to the good old days of
the establishment only doing show votes
to repeal and replace obamacare but not
getting anything done
i don't think that's the the future of
the republican party
what would you expect the president in
this speech to be talking about
number one he will uh position himself
as the alternative to joe biden
uh he i think will will make a speech
that will unify republicans on policy
that i think he he's been working the
phones i was with him all weekend
he wants us to win in 2022 and
stay tuned i think you're going to see
over the next couple of months
donald trump lead the republican party
on policy
and give us the energy we need to take
back the house and the senate
the democrats are doing their part if we
could get behind president trump
and follow his lead we will win in 2022.
if we argue with ourselves we're going
to go
we're going to lose and there's no
reason to lose
losing would be a bad thing i'm not sick
of winning um
so basically you're describing the
leader of the opposition party
any insight as to whether the president
has made up his mind about running in
stay tuned
correspondents of this program have to
tell everything they know i'm just
saying if you want a future you know
when i get my first check i'll i'll tell
you
all right i'll give you the check and
i'll be i'll be standing before one of
these dumb committees in d.c
okay all right senator thank you